[Applause]
[Music]
watch the flowers
[Music]
okay
yeah so you guys are you guys are going
to guard this now for us
money was installed it was two o'clock
in the morning and it was more a
political statement than it was in the
united states
and this is and we're making some sort
of a statement saying to the politicians
that
the soldiers don't see in them
you know instead of taking down the
entire fence
maybe we had just
part of it open so you could have
brought people in and out because now
good point we're going to be back at the
same point where people are now going to
uh cause damage because unless you guys
are here 24 years old
i actually don't think it's part of the
people that cause damage it's going to
be justin trudeau's gang of thieves yes
and if we got to put a man on this
because you guys have what like a
thousand cops in the city right now so
that's not what you guys think so we'll
put a man on it next one this is
[Applause]
no comment no comment because we don't
trust you guys
you didn't do a great job
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a lot of yeah
[Applause]
thank you
thank you
good job guys
[Applause]
you